slap them silly oh
am i gonna get in trouble for that all
right all right all right you guys
ripped me
enough roasted me enough on my previous
sims venture but i really want to create
bear
i really want to become a doctor but
clearly i need some help so
i called on kelsey and peachake
we finally made it this has been
a long time coming for you to officially
tell me how much i suck at sims
in my opinion the game that sims can be
played however you want there's no wrong
way to play the sims
but some people disagree with me just
know
that i'm a better doctor in real life
than i am in sims i gotta put that up
here is my very strange character
yeah i'm loading my home okay here we go
small buildings
okay what do you think you're in what do
you think about that but
why aren't they where are their rooms
connected how do you
connect them there's two options i can
give to you number one i could
i could help you put the rooms together
number two
you could go on the gallery download a
nice home that someone else built
and then move on with your life that's
what i do
okay i'm gonna do that because this
could be the most frustrating thing i've
ever done in my life you know what
building's not for everyone if you want
to just get to the game
my suggestion is always just take
someone else's hard work
and play with it capitalism at its
finest what am i searching yes
you just search starter home pick one
that is in your budget
there's no like baller home oh you have
to have money for it we could cheat you
money if you want money
what i don't know are you do you want to
cheat in this
i don't want to cheat yet kelsey one
step at a time let's just keep it simple
i'll go with this basic budget starter
home
oh look at that little
branch here you go like first of all how
do i see what he's doing inside this
house this creepy guy
on the right bar there's a little arrow
do you see the arrow down
click that down arrow oh oh look what
our guy's up
to he's taking a bath i like to
begin my journey in becoming a physician
because i think thus far i've done a
pretty poop job
number two i would love to make my dog
bear i could definitely help you with
one of those things
[Music]
let's give him a makeover i love giving
makeovers okay
oh my god what who dressed this way what
a vlog
i can appreciate a set of pink pants i
can appreciate some camo
but i don't appreciate the mix of the
two what do people wear to sleep what do
you wear to sleep
probably this probably that okay
i love how not judgmental
this looks like it's a valentine's day
that's adorable
okay set what do people wear to exercise
nowadays what do you i mean
i wear like every outfit you ask like
what do people wear
like do you just wear scrubs i basically
just wear scrubs i mean
it's looking oh where's that booty
shorts
look at the booty there's no booty he's
kind of flat there
he built it all in the shoulder and did
none on the
lower body and honestly a lot of guys do
that
this is simple i can i can vibe with
this okay so that's his like
every day that's his work it's just a
sport
his sleep is funky but i can get with it
party
okay i'm not gonna change that beach
okay i don't know what that is hot
weather hot weather
so when it's hot outside and that's when
it's cold outside
okay we'll leave that because we don't
want to get too advanced here
it's time for work i'm going to work now
this is where i need the most help
kind of ironic because i've done this in
real life
whoa why is there a very scantily
dressed
lady here bella bella goth has come to
say hi
you said he was lonely how do i get him
to oh
she's gone in order to know what to do
at work
it's up on your left hand corner you
have three tasks currently
first task swab a patient for a sample
second task deliver food to a patient on
the exam bed
the third task check a patient's eyes
those are your
current three to do's but look i clicked
on all four of these folks
and they've all been swapped for samples
very interesting well then in that case
let's try to deliver food maybe to one
of them
seems like your coworkers came in early
and already worked
with all of these patients gunners
they're always
coming in before me doing all the work
so i can never get the credit
so let's see what's going on with uh our
fella here
what's her name what's her story who is
she why is she at the hospital today how
do we find that out let's click on her
well molly edmonds and she's a child
she's there alone like where is her
parent
you cannot treat children in the
hospital well in the hospital an
emergency setting you can but
if it's a medical office i cannot treat
children without parental consent unless
she's there to talk about sexually
transmitted infections
she happens to be an emancipated minor
or she wants to discuss obviously an
abuse situation with parents and stuff
like that just so you know kelsey i have
to get you to sign a hipaa form here
because you're learning some privileged
patient information and
privileged patient information is a
protected asset i will assign
the hippo
it's a successfully calibrated x-ray
machine so why don't you go over to an
x-ray machine and see if you can
successfully calibrate one
which one do you think looks most like
an x-ray machine you know none of them
but if you had to guess what you'd put a
person in to x-ray them in this game
what would you guess
this thing yes okay looks like you did
one of them look good
so this guy i feel like he's quite lazy
and unmotivated because he's always
chatting up other people
doing stuff that has nothing to do with
what i'm telling him to do how do i boss
him around more like this is not what i
asked him to turn off his autonomy
and not let him do anything besides what
you tell him to do
is that a thing yes how do i turn off
his autonomy
no more free will sir why is shawn stout
here
totally interfering with my patient care
i don't know
maybe you should fight them is it is
that a thing i mean you could if you
wanted to
with this slap em silly
oh
[Applause]
am i going to get in trouble for that
look at all these people waiting
this place is inefficient how do i do
this research health reports thing i
want to check click on a computer
[Music]
yeah there you go okay come on buddy
step it up
step it up get there wow he's really
walking weird
he needs to pee oh
if the hunker drops all the way down
does he die
yes no really he starves he dies
yeah if all the bladder goes all the way
down he'll pee himself
what is this i did a terrible job today
uh
it's just about efficiency and and
quickness you know you gotta you gotta
be quick about it you gotta get all the
tasks done
my guy's monkeying around the whole time
slapping co-workers
how is he ever gonna expect to work out
all right there you go add a dog oh do
they have all the breeds
yes so search your dog's breed okay
first
oh my god i think this is a chocolate
noof would you say this is a chocolate
noof
i've never seen a chocolate noodle okay
i'm going to show you a chocolate
newfound
oh it's so big his name's chewie like
chewbacca
he's a mini golden doodle so he's golden
retriever poodle
but mostly like a mini poodle bear is a
casual
141 pounds there is like ways more than
me this is fun i think making the dog is
more interesting than actually
me making myself oh he has a first name
and last name he is
bear varshovsky
we have a bear how do i train bear to
become a service dog in this game or an
emotional support animal
oh i don't know if they have that
exactly but you can't train bear for
sure
i'm gonna offer him friendship oh level
one pet training skill
you're better pet trainer than a than a
doctor so far
okay okay that's all right now that
bear's created
can anyone play with bear in this game
yeah so if you want to upload your sim
and your dog to the gallery
anyone could download that just like you
downloaded your house
if you guys get this to a hundred
thousand likes
bear and b will officially be in the
gallery and i want to know what you guys
are doing with it you might you might
have to
search yourself sometime and see if
you're if you're accurately portrayed in
the sims gallery
dude i already exist in this game yeah
that's so nice and they they kind of
gave me cool outfits
this guy's ripped someone gave me way
too much credit
kelsey i think you set me up quite well
to start becoming a doctor i know what i
need to do
i need to spend more time actually being
attentive to my tasks on the top
left-hand corner
i'm going to make some moolah in the
hospital i'm going to make sure my guy
has an empty bladder empty intestine
never hungry
kelsey plug your stuff where do you want
where can people watch you you can find
me
uh anywhere on the internet on youtube
instagram and twitch at kelseydangerous
and uh if you like to check out my sims
shows you can check those out on
buzzfeed multiplayer awesome
you're the bombcaster thank you so much
we will be in touch
we're definitely going to figure out
something fun to do on your channel
because i think the audience is going to
want it after this video
the fact that you were already willing
to slap your co-worker
means that we're going to have a lot of
fun
check this out where teen boys try and
explain what a period is
or my hospital minecraft review that's
right which one are you clicking on
as always stay happy and healthy
you